this month marks the 50th anniversary of
the signing of title ix which outlawed
sex-based discrimination in education in
sports even before its passage women had
already started making their push for
equality in the sporting world like on
june 3rd 1972 when the first ever
all-women road race was held right here
in new york city the 50th running of
that race now the mastercard new york
mini 10k is set to get underway in
central park this morning a race that's
grown from less than 100 women running
to a field of elite and amateur runners
and more than 200 000 finishers to date
i had a chance to look back on how the
mini 10k started and why it's more than
just another weekend race
what do you love about running
well i love the fact that it gets me
away from the trivialities of a day 75
years old and catherine switzer is still
running 40 miles a week that's because
running isn't just something she does
it's a part of who she is when did you
start running and knowing that it was
different for you
when i was 12 my dad said you don't want
to be a cheerleader in high school you
want people to cheer for you you should
go out and start running and make the
field hockey team which is a new thing
in your high school and i began running
every day and it gave me such a sense of
empowerment i felt like i had a victory
under my belt every day nobody could
take away from me the year was 1959
a time when most young girls weren't
encouraged to run or play sports but
rather discouraged i remember the
milkman coming to my mother and saying
your little girl okay i see her out
running and she said no no no she's fine
and then my girlfriends who are
concerned you know you're going to get
big legs you're going to grow hair on
your chest you're never going to have
children all of these myths they really
believe people said that they said that
to me
doctors said that to me definitely my
uterus was going to fall out and i
really should be careful
it was so ridiculous switzer's
determination to run became front page
news in
the 1967 most famous foot race even
attracts a leggy lady just 20 years old
she entered the boston marathon at the
time women weren't allowed there was
nothing about gender on the entry form
and my coach said you have to enter the
race you don't count if you don't enter
the race and so i entered the race but i
signed my name k.v switzer that's how i
got the bib number but in the race with
the bib number the official jumped off
the officials bus furious screamed at me
get the hell out of my race and give me
those numbers and tried to rip the
numbers off of me my coach couldn't get
him away but my burly boyfriend
knocked the official out of the race
instead if i don't finish this race
nobody's going to believe women can do
it so i decided to finish the race and
that changed my life and running
five years later in 1972
women were officially allowed to enter
the boston marathon the publicity led to
more opportunities for women like the
first ever all women's road race with
johnson wax's crazy leg shave cream the
sponsor they thought wouldn't it be cool
to have a women's only marathon in
central park well there are only about
eight of us who could run a marathon
so switzer fellow elite runner nina
kousik and fred lebo the founder of the
new york city marathon came up with the
idea of one lap of central park six
miles or ten thousand meters the crazy
legs mini marathon
a name also inspired by fashion of the
time the mini skirt so the race then
became also an emblem of women's
equality
and
feistiness and freedom because the
miniskirt was that emblem and now we had
our very own race but not without some
challenges the biggest challenge was
convincing women to come
and and really yes the biggest challenge
was because they maybe jogged a mile or
two a day but now this was six miles and
that really scared them we sent out so
many entries we had 78 women show up and
with that i was gonna at the time that
was a huge number it was huge we said
it's going to be a success and it was it
really was did it feel
that you had to compromise in some ways
to get this also or no well we didn't
feel we had to compromise but fred
lebeau was really an operator and he was
trying anything to get publicity and he
would do things like go to the playboy
bunny club and recruit playboy bunnies
to come for a photo op now that we
didn't really like to promote the race
right yeah but you know we all said look
fred just wants the publicity right
however and if we get to run yeah when
the gun went off it was a serious race
switzer still has the t-shirt she wore
in the inaugural race 50 years later i
can still get into it and while the race
no longer has its crazy legs designation
now the new york mini 10k there is still
a nod to the original name thanks to
runners like julianne grace and her
daughter dede beck
the two are crazy legs runners meaning
they have at least 15 new york mini 10ks
under their belts what makes you go back
here absolutely incredible i think you
know just that feeling of sisterhood
with all these other women runners you
know 5 000 8 000 women out there
julianne has 45 finishes missing just
one after her first in 1975. i was very
nervous
because i hadn't run 10 kilometers and
then during the race i remember feeling
just
i'm doing this i'm doing this and
i was 195th
out of
276 finishers
i wasn't lost so that was pretty good
and i felt so great i felt i had done
something remarkable dede then followed
in her mother's footsteps and now has 42
straight finishes despite a recent
diagnosis of the muscle disease dystonia
i can still participate with the
crutches
and you know still be part of it did you
ever think this is too tough to do this
with a disability like this no i didn't
i ran it in 2019 with the dystonia and
with you know kind of tripping and
stumbling and slowly but i made it and
then 2020 it was canceled and since i
did it last year
i know i can do it this year after all
it's tradition with dee dee's three
daughters a third generation in the
family also running each june
generationally
to pass something like this on what does
that mean to you
it's hard to describe in words to have
my daughter follow along with something
i love
and to have
her daughters my three granddaughters to
have these girls show up for the mini it
makes me so proud
it makes me
feel loved
and ensures the impact of the new york
mini marathon will live on it's not just
about running it's about what women have
achieved
since the 1970s how much women have
achieved in education in careers in
athletics it's about women's progress
through the years i mean that's what it
means to me in many ways it really does
it's symbolic i hope to do it every year
i can that's why i show up
that's a good reason so how about this
for progress women now make up more than
half the runners out there that started
in 2019
it's an amazing thing to see the number
of women that come out year after year
catherine switzer is going to be wearing
that shirt she still had today at the
race which is getting underway and then
also she told me this is what inspired
her to then push to get women in the
olympics in the marathon which was joan
benoit which ended up being what 12
years later after this so the push that
they have made and that the new york
road runners have made by keeping this
race when they didn't have sponsors at
certain times it's just really critical
to be a reminder of where we were and
where we are now katherine's sister's
something else
had a chance to talk to her about 10
years ago but it's her poise and her
absolute determination that has gotten
us to where we are today so excited for
her why are you not running via live
shots yeah or you could be broadcasting
from the race that's what we would like
to see
i was in boston last night yeah oh we
won't talk about that but that is a good
idea